frère de sang frères de sang dans leurs
clips comme dans la vie big flo et oli
respire le rap et cultive le seconde et
d'horaires ma tête bouge tellement fort
que je vais me péter le coup les mecs se
prennent pour les meilleurs mais tout le
monde sait que c'est noël avant l'heure
mais pas le flou les chaînes mais pas le
flou sur sa vie voir flou qui est grave
ça le footsie perd atteint aussi
pommevic ce jour là les deux frangins
sont au micro dans la cour de leur lycée
l'impasse le bac cette année l'autre est
en seconde
le rap n'est pour l'instant qu'une
option facultative et ferme ta gueule et
pas qu'on soit il c'est à lèvres et le
sourire aux lèvres
j'en ai jeunes en mp tu es fou que et
donc c'est vrai que parfois on aimerait
espérer vivre durable mais bon c c'est
des choses tellement éphémère enfin
c'est déjà tellement aléatoires c'est on
ne peut pas le on ne peut pas le gérer
qu'on voit là exactement aléatoire c'est
le mot que je cherchais la recherche du
mot juste et de la musique qui
l'habillera attention les yeux sur scène
big flo et oli triture les textes les
samples les boîtes à rythmes avec
parfois la envie de revenir à des sons
plus acoustique
pour brouiller les pistes des
territoires durables ces deux
explorateurs sont aussi élève au
conservatoire de musique pour au lycée
la trompette qui s'est imposé une
partition d'albinoni de se mettre au
service du rap voit les choses qui se
ressent bien la respiration déjà ensuite
la concentration le débit aussi ça peut
faire penser à ce qu'on fait quand j'ai
des fois on a toujours été au
conservatoire elle a toujours été dans
les milieux râble dans l'histoire et rap
donc on apprend à vivre dans les deux et
ça se passe plutôt bien
big flo lui et aux baguettes depuis
l'âge de 6 ans et florian a été
officiellement le premier rappeur on va
dire un examen quoi à rappeler ici au
camp soit on était très fiable ça et je
croise un marché non ouais il ya près de
cinquante kilos
pourtant c'est plus lourd que vous
devrez argument qui fait le buzz sur
internet
plusieurs centaines de milliers de clics
pour voir leur match de rap ou leur clip
big flo et oli font souffler un vent
léger sur la musique qui les unit la
musique me connaît ses classiques tout
le monde les rockeurs et connaissent
tous les groupes mythiques tout ça est
dans le rap n'a pas eu cet échange entre
les générations s'est pas fait la force
justement d'aller dans le commercial de
d'aller dans les personnages gangsta est
tous assez ses loges du concert un peu
sali les mains parce qu'on sait mentir à
nous mêmes et on a perdu nos valeurs big
flo et oli tailleur de mou sculpteur de
sons en plus doués pour l'improvisation
jeu sera du flou à la batterie pour
france 3
[Musique]